what if I have a degree in something  else that's not Cloud can I still land a  cloud at all well I would consider that  a net positive find ways to leverage  your non-tech skill set to make you a  more attractive candidate I have  interest in art and painting and drawing  and I brought that into Cloud developer  relations you might have a background in  Communications or research or news think  of ways to bring that diverse background  into cloud and then pick a technical  path that excites you it may be  serverless or kubernetes machine  learning data science whatever you fancy  pick that and move on with the cloud  role